but first the news of the day was for
the most part unfortunately political
our hapless media turned out the usual
dreary menu of palace intrigue stories
who would the West Wing supports a
shutdown who doesn't as if any of that
matters or anyone cares or will even
remember the names of these people ten
years from now we will not because in
the scheme of things this is irrelevant
what matters is protecting the country
suddenly every politician in America is
claiming a monopoly on the best course
forward we must do this when they say
that it ought to make you nervous they
can't all be right most of them can be
self-righteous though and they are
here's New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
who most of the time has been credible
on this subject but today explaining
that if you don't support precisely the
kind of quarantine he supports you're
trying to kill his mother my mother is
not expendable and your mother is not
expendable and our brothers and sisters
are not expendable and we're not going
to accept a premise that human life is
disposable human life is not disposable
lectures the man who just signed a law
legalizing abortion until birth all
right take a deep breath governor in a
moment like this talk like that
overstatement hyperbole is not helpful
the last thing we need is another dose
of moral blackmail to add the long list
of those what we do need instead is
honesty and the people on television are
not helping most of the time most of
them just believe what they're told by
sources they think they agree with and
then they repeat it to us at this point
they're not even asking the most basic
questions on our behalf and here's the
most basic question of all which we
should ask what is the shape of this
epidemic and the truth is we don't
really know the government isn't doing
large-scale randomized tests of the
population thanks to the serial
incompetence of our health establishment
we still don't have enough tests to do
that this means we have no real idea how
many Americans have been infected so far
there's no baseline for our measurements
of anything across a population of 320
million people we can't know exactly how
easily chrono virus spreads we don't
know the physical effects on the
average infected person we don't know
the death rate flatten the curve we're
not sure what the curve really is and
that's not our opinion by the way it's
elementary science at this point it
would be very helpful if the people
trying to influence policy admitted all
of this straightforwardly instead of
pretending at high volume they've got
some cure that will absolutely
positively work they don't know that
they can't know that inform guesses are
the best they have let's not lie about
it by the way this is an argument
against quarantines or shutdowns or
whatever we're calling them but it is a
reminder to proceed with humility and
honesty at all times one thing we do
know at this point is that America will
not be the same after this is over some
of the changes will be positive and
hopefully lasting if you found yourself
calling the people you love more often
recently you've had a taste of that but
there are also be problems to fix a lot
of problems here are three that we'll be
following on this show because at this
point they seem like the biggest threats
America is likely to face once this
virus passes and the first of those is a
global depression already you're hearing
Twitter pundits schooled anyone who
worries about the country's economic
health is if that were the same as
carrying water for Wall Street lives are
worth more than share prices they scream
and of course they're right lives are
worth more than share prices but it's
not really about share price the finance
moguls are gonna be fine no matter what
happens to the economy not much likely
change for poor people either they will
remain poor but the middle class the
middle class could be wiped out by what
we're watching right now the service
industry middle management small
business independent contractors people
like those make this country work and
more important they keep it stable and
they're the ones in deepest peril
tonight a lasting hit to the middle
class would be a catastrophe for
everyone rich or poor you don't want to
live in an impoverished country with a
thin layer of rich people at the top
that's a recipe for suffering and for
never ending political volatility it's
the story of much of the world so we
know that for certain and suddenly for
the first time ever it's a possibility
here and our first priority has to be
preventing that or our grandchildren
will regret it deeply the next concern
going forward is China
now China ultimately is responsible for
this virus literally which they hid and
they lied about and allowing about even
but the threat extends far beyond the
current pandemic it's entirely possible
sadly that the Chinese coronavirus makes
China stronger in the end even as it
weakens us in America China already has
a deeper manufacturing base than we do
it has a far larger population soon it
will have the biggest economy on earth
how long before theirs is the world's
reserve currency that would be the end
of American economic dominance almost
instantly it's entirely possible that we
can wake up a few years now and find
China in charge do you member the
revulsion you felt the gut-level
revulsion you felt as you watched NBA
stars sucking up to the Chinese
Politburo that could be all of us now
we've been headed to this place for a
while the crisis that we're currently
going through could be enough to push us
to the next place
disasters often accelerate trends that
are already in progress you think
they're gonna change everything but
instead they just make things worse in
the very same way so what is the plan to
stop China from taking advantage of the
chaos they've unleashed and we are
suffering through we ought to have a
plan for that we need to and finally as
we do all we can to fight this pandemic
we should make sure that we don't lose
the most important part of our
birthright as Americans and we know what
that is it's the right to think and say
what we believe is true freedom of
conscience may be undervalued right now
but it underpins everything we have it
is the foundation of a free and a decent
society it's under attack by politicians
but most dangerously it's under attack
by multinational tech monopolies at this
very moment Twitter has decided to
control what you're allowed to know
about the coronavirus other tech
companies have done the same Twitter's
deleting what it calls quote
misinformation about the pandemic some
of it is some of it isn't the actual
data is a moving target
there aren't many certain facts about
coronavirus so censoring people who say
unusual things probably isn't going to
get you to a solution but they're doing
it anyway and yet at the same time
Twitter leaves Chinese state propaganda
untouched every day if you're following
you'll notice the Chinese government
spokesman claims that coronavirus
actually originated here in the US
that's totally untrue but none of these
lies have been taken down by Twitter
keep in mind Twitter is banned in China
but they're still doing China's bidding
what does that tell you
it's not a small thing it's a trend a
collusion between big multinationals and
authoritarian governments to make you
obey
that's not paranoid talk it's real and
you should worry about it